[Music]
I was fully dreading coming to this
wedding until you showed
up could I get a cranberry juice with
ice and vodka when I first saw you I
thought that we should have sex in the
code
closet
yeah wait hold on I am kind of in a
weird place yeah you're in a beach club
coat closet you think that we could just
talk for a
minute romantic humiliations it's my
specialty I don't care the first person
to ever go down on me we just going to
steamroll right on through I came in my
own
eye okay go
on I've had too many girlfriends over
the past couple years I can't figure it
out yeah we've all been there tell me
what I'll give you some of this pie if
you tell me more about your
past
[Music]
it's not like I don't come with my own
complications we're engaged
oh wait you were
engaged lasted 13 days impressive that
is incredibly insulting but I see what
you mean will you welcome into the train
station I actually have class no you
don't I like this chick she's really hot
I know just wish I would have ended
things more great
y you ever see her
again this would never work you are
someone who cannot be counted on you've
run out on every guy you've ever been
with I'm a mess and I don't have any
answers but maybe you and I could figure
it out
together usually I feel so alone in my
memories but it's different with you woo
I'm happy to tell you a few more
embarrassing stories about my love life
well I promise not to laugh I
promise not to laugh
much you ever change your
[Music]
mind